الآن يرى بيني عضوًا في
مجلس الوزراء الحربي الإسرائيلي يقول إن حماس لم تعد
تسيطر على أجزاء كبيرة من قطاع غزة،
لكن إسرائيل تعتقد أن 132 رهينة
ما زالوا محتجزين هناك، وينضم إليّ
من تل أبيب الآن مارك ريجيف كبير
مستشاري رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي.
مرحبًا بكم مرة أخرى معالي الوزير مارك ريجيف في
البرنامج، شكرًا لكم على استضافتي، لذا هل يمكنني أن
أسألكم أولاً عما
أخبرني به الدكتور هارينجتون عن هذه الحكايات المتوافقة مع
ما يقوله الكثيرون في المجتمع الدولي
وأريد فقط أن
أسألك، هل تعلمون كل شيء؟  يقول أصدقاؤك هنا في
الولايات المتحدة في كل مكان إنه كان على إسرائيل بالطبع أن
تشن هجومًا ضد
الإرهاب الذي تم ارتكابه أه في
7 أكتوبر، لكن اتضح أنه
كلما طال أمده، لم يتم تنفيذه
بشكل صحيح، لذا أعتقد أنني أريد ذلك  أعرف منك إلى
متى يمكن لديمقراطية تعرف أنك
تسمي نفسك
ديمقراطية أخلاقية أن تستمر في مشاهدة ما
يتكشف في غزة الآن، الأطفال
والنساء، أعني أننا أجرينا للتو مناقشة
حول الأزمة في
النظام الصحي في غزة و  السؤال الواضح الذي يجب
طرحه هو لماذا توجد أزمة في
النظام الصحي في غزة، لم تكن إسرائيل
تريد ذلك، ولكن كما تم الإبلاغ عنه
وتوثيقه، لدى حماس
استراتيجية متعمدة لبناء هيكلها العسكري
داخل المستشفيات، كنا
نفضل ذلك كثيرًا كنظام استبدادي  المواقع
التي كانت المستشفيات
خارج الصراع ولكن لسوء الحظ
اتخذت حماس قرارًا استراتيجيًا
ليس في مستشفى واحد ولا في
مستشفيين ولكن في جميع أنحاء قطاع غزة قامت
حماس ببناء
بنية تحتية عسكرية عسكرية داخل وتحت
المستشفيات رأينا أنفاقًا ورأينا أسلحة رهائن
الذين ذكرتهم
منذ قليل والذين تم اختطافهم
في 7 أكتوبر أبلغوا عن نقلهم
إلى أقبية داخل
المستشفيات واحتجازهم ليس للعلاج الطبي، لقد تم
احتجازهم هناك أه تم الاعتداء عليهم هناك هناك فيديو من أه
مقاطع فيديو من المستشفى تظهر أه  يتم نقل
الأشخاص المختطفين عبر المستشفى
أه نعرف مراكز القيادة والسيطرة
أسفل المستشفيات كنا
مجبرين على القتال حول المستشفيات وعندما
دخلنا المستشفيات قمنا بذلك
جراحيًا قدر الإمكان
لتجنب إيذاء الموظفين والمرضى وما
إلى ذلك ولكن  إذا كانت هناك أزمة في
النظام الصحي في غزة فمن الواضح أن ذلك
بسبب سلوك حماس المتعمد
باستخدام تلك المستشفيات كدرع
ضد القانون الدولي كدرع
لآلتها العسكرية Mark GRE. أنا
أعلم أن هذا هو موقفكم وأعلم أنكم
وجدتم بعض  الأنفاق أم أنا
أعلم أيضًا أنا أعلم أنني رأيتهم لقد رأيت
صورك لهم أه لقد رأينا
أيضًا العديد من التحقيقات التي أجرتها
مؤسسات إعلامية غربية لم تقم
فعليًا بعد بربط
غرفة المستشفى بمركز قيادة أو
اتصال مع  ولكن هذا
هو موقفك، سؤالي لك هو
الجنرال بتريوس، السيناتور فان هولاند،
القادة في جميع أنحاء العالم، وزير
الخارجية، مجلس الأمن القومي،
رئيس الولايات المتحدة
الفرنسية، المملكة المتحدة في كل مكان، يقول نعم،
لديك الحق في الاستقلال الذاتي.  الدفاع ولكن هذه
الخسائر في صفوف المدنيين كثيرة جدًا، لذا
سؤالي لك هو: ألا توجد
طريقة عسكرية لفصل المدنيين
ورعاية المدنيين كما قال بتريوس إنه
خاض العديد من الحروب ضد
الإرهابيين في المناطق المدنية،
ألم تكن هناك
طريقة أفضل أولاً  كل ما في الأمر أننا لا نريد أن نرى
أي مدنيين يُقتلون، وأكرر أننا
لا نريد أن نرى أي مدنيين
محاصرين في تبادل إطلاق النار بين حماس
وقوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية، ولكننا
قلنا إننا نواجه
عدوًا وحشيًا ومروعًا.  الذي
يدفن نفسه عمدا ليس فقط في
المستشفيات ولكن في
الأحياء السكنية في المدارس وفي
مرافق الأمم المتحدة في المساجد وتحت
غزة تحت مدن غزة، حسنًا
حيث لا تستطيع الكاميرات في كثير من الأحيان الوصول إلى هناك
شبكة إرهابية جوفية من الأنفاق
والمخابئ ومواقع إطلاق الصواريخ ومستودعات
الأسلحة  القيادة والسيطرة لقد
استغرق كاماس أكثر من 16 عامًا لتثبيت
نفسه، ولهذا السبب ستستغرق هذه العملية بعض
الوقت، وعلى الرغم من أننا نبذل
قصارى جهدنا لتجنب وقوع المدنيين
في مرمى النيران، فإن حماس لديها
استراتيجية متعمدة تتمثل في استخدام
المدنيين كنقطة انطلاق.  الدرع البشري يجعل
مهمتنا أكثر صعوبة بكثير، لقد
قلت ذلك ولكني أريد أن أسألك
في هذه الحالة لماذا إذن يحصل
الطبيب البريطاني الذي دخل
بموافقة إسرائيلية ومصرية على جميع
الأذونات الأخرى التي يحتاجونها  للتواصل مع
NOS أم، لماذا شاهدت شاحنة
تم إرجاعها مليئة
بحفاضات الأطفال، لماذا أخبرني السيناتور فان هولاند
والمنظمات الدولية الأخرى
أن أصدقاء إسرائيل هم المسؤولون عن مساعدة بعض
هؤلاء المدنيين في الحصول على المساعدات الإنسانية
الأمر متروك لك الآن لأنه من
المعقد جدًا إدخال هذه الشاحنات ونراهم
يتم إعادتهم، فهل
هناك أي طريقة ينبغي عليك أو يمكنك
تسريع عملية توصيل المساعدات الإنسانية
والأدوية إليها، لذا أريد توضيح تلك
الشاحنة  على وجه التحديد، وهذا
مثال جيد لأن تلك الشاحنة على وجه التحديد
كانت مرخصة من قبل إسرائيل وتم
تفتيشها من قبل إسرائيل وكان من الممكن أن تكون قد
دخلت قطاع غزة من
وجهة نظرنا ولكن من الواضح أنه كانت هناك
مشاكل على الحدود حيث أن إسرائيل
ليست على حدود غزة المصرية بالنسبة لها
سيتم إيقافه ولم يكن هناك مجال أو
شيء من هذا القبيل للعبور في ذلك اليوم ولكن
إسرائيل فتحت
معبر كيم شالوم الإضافي لأننا نريد
التأكد من وصول المساعدات الإنسانية إلى
قطاع غزة وكذلك
السكان المدنيين في غزة.  ليس
هدفًا لعمليتنا العسكرية،
هناك قضايا أخرى متضمنة هنا ولكن
إسرائيل لم تمنع تلك الشاحنة من
الدخول، أريد أن أكون واضحًا بنسبة 100%
بشأن ذلك ومع ذلك
يقول السيناتور إنني أتحدث عن
الحدود  على حدود إسرائيل مع غزة،
إنها بطيئة جدًا، بطيئة جدًا، والأمر متروك
لك لأنك تتحكم في ذلك
لتسريعه بالفعل، كما نعلم من
الأمم المتحدة أن هناك مجاعة وظروف ما
قبل المجاعة تطارد غزة
وأعتقد أن السؤال جيد
السؤال ذو الصلة هو هل يمكنك التأكيد على
أنه كان هناك ما تقوله قطر عن
نوع من الصفقة لإرسال نوع ما
من المساعدات الإنسانية، هل يمكنك أن تخبرنا ما هو ذلك
بالنسبة للرهائن الإسرائيليين ولشعب
غزة، لذا أولاً وقبل كل شيء أنا  أريد أن أكون واضحا
في الأسبوع الأول من هذه الحرب
اتخذ مجلس الوزراء الأمني ​​الإسرائيلي
قرارا بأنه ونحن نلاحق حماس
لتدمير آلتها العسكرية ويجب
أه في نفس الوقت بالتوازي
لن تكون هناك أي قيود على الإطلاق
على الغذاء  يدخل دواء الماء إلى
قطاع غزة وهذه هي سياستنا، فلماذا
إذن قال وزير دفاعكم أن هناك
حصارًا قال ذلك بنفسه لا طعام
ولا ماء ولا وقود ولا دواء هذا ما
قاله جالان، لا أعرف ما الذي أعرفه.
لا، هذا ليس صحيحًا، أكتوبر الذي
تتحدث فيه عن المجيء نعم إلى
غزة، أنت تتحدث عن المعابر
من إسرائيل، لذا في البداية
سمحنا لذلك بالمرور عبر
المعبر المصري في رفح ثم فتحنا
معبرًا  بعد بضعة أسابيع فتحنا عندما
رأينا أن هناك حاجة أكبر
لفتح معبر كوم شالون وهو
معبرنا ولكن عليك أن تفهم
بعد مذبحة 7 أكتوبر،
كان الشعور في إسرائيل هو أنك تعلم أن
المعابر تعرضت لهجوم من قبل الكباس  لقد
فجر الإرهابيون
فكرة أنهم هاجمونا للتو
وعلينا أن نعمل كالمعتاد مع غزة،
وهذا بالطبع كان صعبًا في النهاية،
اتخذنا قرارًا بفتح
المعبر الإسرائيلي لأننا أردنا أن
نفهم الآن ذلك  لأكون صريحًا،
ما نحن على استعداد لتفتيشه وإرساله
يمكننا أن نتلقى اليوم
من المجتمع الدولي لإرساله
إلى غزة أكثر بكثير مما يمكننا التعامل
معه إذا كان هناك تأخير، فهذا ليس
بسبب
إسرائيل.